well I probably have as big an ego which  anybody you know  hey there murdered willye 30 years ago a  chess match with Ray Charles taught a  very confident Willie a lesson in  humility  murrieta we're doing a show in Austin he  was staying over the hotel and I went  over to say hello comes the door and it  was light in the hallway there and then  we walked into the living room  that was no light yeah if he sit down  here and I'll sit down there he got out  to chessboard his chess pieces were all  there were no color they were all the  same color unpainted wood you know but  he could feel of them until they were so  needless to say kick my ass about three  games in a row I said thank you right  let's go saying  but I didn't tell him that the next time  we played I want you to do it with the  lights on